I've heard a lot about parasite cleanses.
Is this something necessary to do?
And also, would it be something that my husband and kids should do also?
What do you recommend?
Well, similar to supporting detoxification, I would have a similar answer to supporting
pathogens, except that, you know, pathogens, yes, they're ubiquitous, meaning they're everywhere.
And yes, we are picking up parasites, especially if you have animals, if you have pets, cats,
dogs.
That's really where you're picking up 90% of your parasites, not necessarily dietary.
Now, understand, how do parasites get into us?
So most of the time parasites come into our body orally.
Yes, you can have hookworms, especially down south if you're walking around in the grass
and hookworms are very common to get into your skin.
That's why they're named that way, and they burrow into your skin and get into your blood
that way.
But most pathogens, most parasites are ingested.
Yes, you can get viruses and bacteria through the nasal cavity and through the lungs.
But we're talking about neuroscience here.
Most of those are going to be ingested.
And why do people get parasites anyhow?
Well, the number one reason why we get parasites, not talking about source, but the number one
reason why we get parasites is because we have a decreased hydrochloric acid in the stomach.
So hypochloridria is the number one reason why we get parasites.
Why do you say that?
Because if we had healthy stomach acid, so our pH of our stomach was at 1.5 to 2.5 an
all times.
And our dog licked our face and we got eggs of parasites because of the dog had parasites.
We get that in our mouth and we swallow that.
Or we eat sushi and we get parasites through raw fishers, whatever oral source or through
food that even other pathogens and bacteria through food, let's say we were exposed, went
to a restaurant and person had unclean hands.
It was unclean kitchen and we have bacteria in the kitchen and we get that in our food and
we eat the food.
Now we got food poisoning.
The number one way to prevent against food poisoning and any oral source of parasites or
bacteria is to have healthy HCl in your stomach.
If you have healthy HCl in your stomach, 99% of things are going to survive that.
So bacteria will be killed, parasites, eggs will be killed by the HCl in the stomach and
then we never get parasites.
But the problem is the number one issue in all the world, health wise, probably is hypochloridria,
decreased stomach acid.
And why is that?
Because we're exposed to chemicals, diets, food colorings, additives, flavorings, pesticides,
herbicides, you name it.
They damage the parietal cells of the stomach.
That's the cell in the stomach that makes HCl.
Then we end up with hypochloridria and it's a whole cascade of issues.
We have an increased risk of food issues, bacteria, viruses, other pathogens like parasites coming
through food or through the oral cavity into the stomach that survive the stomach because
the pH of the stomach is now 4.0 or something.
Close into the swelling test and it starts growing and that's where we get infections.
So our oral source of defense against pathogens is HCl.
That's why I literally have recommended for every single patient to be taking an HCl product.
So clear digests, HCl's I'm, that is your best thing to take to prevent pathogens.
Number two, let's say we already have pathogens, we already have parasites, what if I already
have them?
I just started taking that and if I start taking HCl today and I already have parasites
in my intestinal tract or in my liver, is that going to help kill that?
No.
No we have to talk about parasite cleanses.
So what are parasite cleanses?
Well parasite cleanses my definition is simply taking anti-parasitic nutrition.
So there's different anti-parasitic nutrition that can be better for certain types of parasites
quote pathogens than others.
So let's say I have Hpylorin, the number one, it's not a parasite, that's a bacteria.
But that's the number one pathogen that one would have because of hypochloridria again
would be garlic, oregano, burberry, those would be your biggest choices for that.
A bacterial infection in a gut, you could say the same thing, burberry, oregano, garlic.
How about parasites?
Well, there's a whole bunch of different herbs that can be good for parasites.
Or like a burberry and oregano could be good for parasites as well.
But a whole bunch of other things, cloves, and we have a product called ParaClear.
We also have some products that you have to take like four different supplements to do this
cleanse.
I've just in favor of taking less stuff.
So I like ParaClear simply because if you looked at the bottle, it's got...
This really covers a broad spectrum of parasites.
I mean, ParaClear could be greatly used for Hpylorin as well.
So I like ParaClear because it's a one bottle now because there's so much in it, you might
have to take more pills than cells, but it's easier to take because you're just taking
one bottle instead of remember to take two of the para one, two of the para, two of the
para, you know, it's just simpler.
So can anybody do ParaClear?
Yes, the only caveat to doing these things though is these things are immune stimulators.
So if a person has a known autoimmune disease, they could feel worse doing a parasite cleanse
because most parasite cleanse are going to have immune stimulators in them.
So learn more about that on the autoimmune course.
I won't go into that.
I've talked about that many times, but if you have a known autoimmune disorder and you're
suffering from that autoimmune disorder and doing a parasite cleanse thinking that you're
going to get better could actually make you worse because you're stimulating your immune
system.
You're going to destroy that which you have antibodies against, which is your old self tissue.
I go into that ad nausea on the autoimmune course.
If you want to learn more about that, you can.
But if you don't think you have an autoimmune disease and I'm thinking my husband and my kids
may have parasites using paraClear can be a good thing to do.
Now, when I've tested people for parasites on paraClear and they show positive for parasites,
you tend to have to take like six to nine to those a day.
I've had even people take 12 to 15 a day for a short period of time, but just on a regular
basis, taking three to six of them for a week may be perfectly fine to knock something out.
So the product is paraClear, it's a cutters clinic product.